ces images qui ont fait le tour du monde
non pas seulement choqué la planète
elles ont aussi causé la disparition de
donald trump et de groupes extrémistes
sur les réseaux sociaux
l'un après l'autre les géants du web ont
réduit au silence le président mais
aussi ses actuels ou anciens
collaborateurs comme steve banane qui a
vu sa baladodiffusion retirée de youtube
même le service de diffusion en direct
switch qui appartient à amazon a
suspendu le compte du président il n'en
fallait pas plus pour que le clan trump
crié à la violation de la liberté
d'expression selon cet analyste des
médias le premier amendement de la
constitution américaine qui interdit les
restrictions de la liberté de parole
s'applique aux gouvernements pour les
compagnies privées
c'est autre chose la droite s'est alors
rabattu sur parole un sorte de twitter
de prédilection pour la droite ultra
conservatrice
il est groupe complotistes mais là
encore google et apple ont retiré
l'application de leurs services et
amazon a viré par l'un de ses serveurs
mettant hors ligne la plateforme ce
grand ménage depuis l'insurrection de
mercredi dernier comporte malgré tout un
risque celui d'hier entre semaine de
rétrécir la conversation politique en
général mais la désinformation continue
de se propager malgré tout explique
chris lowell sur d'autres réseaux comme
gab qui a su refaire le plein d'abonnés
depuis la purge sur le web
un réseau qui modère à peine ce qui se
dit et se partagent dans ce
chamboulement dit-il il va falloir
décider ce qui est services essentiels
ou pas dans le domaine des
communications sur internet singh et
surtout réglementés pour éviter que les
plus grandes compagnies n'est pas ce
pouvoir démesuré de choisir qui peut
dire quoi en moins d'une semaine donald
trump n'a pas seulement perdu la
majorité de ses porte voix sur le web
chauffailles le géant du commerce en
ligne aussi décidé de retirer du web les
magasins virtuels du président qui
vendait des produits dérivés
l'impact est colossal mais certains
estiment qu'après le 6 janvier ce n'est
pas vraiment trop peu
c'est surtout trop tard c'est en tout
cas le début d'une longue réflexion sur
le pouvoir de censure des géants du web
et l'entrée inévitable des politiciens
dans la mêlée ici frédéric arnold
radio-canada washington